Iran is putting the world on notice that
it will continue to reduce its
compliance with its nuclear deal
commitments made with several countries
unless they help it combat painful
economic sanctions imposed by the US the
u.s. withdrew from that Accord Iran's
president made the warning during a
meeting with Russian Chinese and other
Asian leaders in Tajikistan this comes
one day after President Trump accused
Iran of attacking two oil tankers this
week in the Gulf of Oman Charlie d'Agata
is in the United Arab Emirates Charlie
what can you tell us good morning well
the Trump administration may be piling
up evidence that Iran is to be blamed
for it's now become a series of attacks
here the international community remains
divided Germany's foreign minister has
cast doubt France remains uncommitted
and even here in the UAE
they've been reluctant to point the
finger of blame directly in Iran
president Trump says he has no doubt
who's behind back-to-back explosions
that damaged two oil tankers here in the
Gulf of Oman on Thursday
well Iran did do it and you know they
did it because you saw the boat I guess
one of the mines didn't explode and it's
probably got essentially Iran written
all over it what he's referring to
images released from the US military
showing one of the tankers with a hole
blown in the starboard side and what
military officials say is an unexploded
mine still attached to the hull later an
American aircraft captured this footage
what the US says is an Iranian boat with
Islamic Revolutionary Guards seen
detaching the mine and making off with
it and that was the boat that was them
and they didn't want the evidence left
behind US investigators boarded the
Japanese tanker and found pieces of the
magnet that fixed the mind to the ship
the other tanker Norwegian owned front
Altair sustained three explosions and
burned for hours Iran insists it had
nothing to do with Thursday's attacks
and they follow similar coordinated
attacks less than a month ago that
targeted for tankers right off this port
iran denies any involvement in those
attacks to
passing Iranian cargo ship rescued the
crew of the Altair but then Iranian
military boats reportedly surrounded the
ship and ordered the crew into their
custody that 23 member crew is still
believed to be in Iranian hands cranking
up further the tensions in this region
that have been rising for the past few
weeks now Trump administration officials
are looking to garner support from US
allies we have an international
situation there in the MOU it's not a
u.s. situation and the focus for myself
an ambassador Bolton the secretary
Pompeo is to build international
consensus to this international problem
that International Cooperation might
look like re flagging oil tankers
traveling through what's now clearly
become a dangerous stretch of water and
essentially providing military escort
that was something done during the
height of tensions here in the 1980s
Dana
Charlie thank you